the Joe Rogan experience yeah no I I
heard more about the simulation idea
well that's another that's another idea
but that's a Ilan believes that he
believes that it's very possible like
like one of the things they said if you
could ask AI what what would you ask you
said what's beyond the simulation he
believes this is a simulation but if
you're Elon Musk of course she'd believe
it's a simulation people were letting
you drill tunnels under LA and shoot
Rockets off into space you might get
electric cars I mean he's he's literally
living like some character in a movie
that's 4x or something yeah but if
you're in a simulation is nothing you
can do about it right so just might as
well just do what we do it all so it's
like great way to think like what is a
simulation if everything is a simulation
it's still life right like the existence
exactly everything you're accustomed to
and everything you experience and if it
is a simulation at least some aspects of
this are comfortably or comfortingly
like obvious like work hard you can get
better things right you can you know be
nice to people they're nice to you you
like B be a good friend you get good
friends eat healthy food you're
healthier there's there's like some
comfort to the lack of meaning that
there's there's certainly some variables
that are very difficult to account for
but there's also there's a surprising
amount of life that's pretty
straightforward so it is a simulation
it's not the most difficult one to
follow it's pretty crazy and chaotic but
there's there's a lot of comfort in it
like as much as we try to dwell on the
horrors of humanity and certainly a lot
of them disguise a lot of beauty in
people do and there's a lot of cool [ __ ]
in people yeah I mean when you focus on
that then yeah then there's real growth
I was at the Comedy Store last night
till like two o'clock in the morning in
this comedian's bar just hanging out
with all these comedians we're just
laughing and talking and there's no no
audience just a bunch of people that get
paid to make people laugh on Jon Stewart
was back there Michelle wolf and all
these really funny comics Rob
laughing having a great time and talking
and it was like wow this is so nice and
reward so fun it's rewarding it's like
there's cool things in this life yeah if
you can find good people and friends and
and communicate and and and spread love
and have interesting fascinating
thought-provoking conversations there's
a lot of really positive things right so
this is a simulation it's pretty badass
DiMeo
yeah Joe Rogan you know making a brain
foundation I mean what a [ __ ] great
simulation you're in absolutely I think
yeah it's like you you can make what you
want of it I mean it's not it might not
be the dream like the Elon Musk scenario
right away but it takes time to get
there well you don't want that dream I
don't want his dream yeah exactly his
dreams crazy well I mean his dream of
like I mean like you said he's just like
almost the superhero is Bruce Wayne you
know doing whatever you know he's he's
Iron Man you know well you know some
some cars have small engines right
there's Honda Civics out there and then
there's [ __ ] rocket cars he's got
some sort of crazy quantum rocket car
engine for a brain yeah have you talked
to him no I haven't he's a trip he's
actually on the on the list of people I
would love to be in the studio with to
make music with and you know just get
into his mind a bit
I've been putting that out there to the
universe he's one of those guys when
you're talking to him you have this
feeling that he's running code in the
background wise time I think he just
gets bored with like regular mundane
conversations and he's got 50 million
things going on constantly and he's also
trying like he was talking about it to
me about how difficult is to manage his
minds like you wouldn't want to be me he
thought he was crazy when he was younger
cause he like so much was bouncing
around in his head and he realized that
other people weren't like that and it's
like oh no but I'm alone yeah I mean
like literally he's probably alone who
the [ __ ] is like that guy right in terms
of like a public intellectual who's
responsible for so many groundbreaking
technologies you know the number one
electric car in the world like SpaceX
tunneling under la yeah
whirring company it's a [ __ ] he's a
crazy man yeah fast thank God he's
around though yeah people like that it's
so cool to have like a true outlier you
know someone was just really out there
and oh man he's constantly attacked and
maligned and people are misrepresenting
him and you know people like all the
crabs in a bucket don't like it yeah I
pull him down yeah - god damn smart all
these people that fancy themselves smart
you meet that guy you're like oh okay
there's levels of this game yeah no he's
he's like by the top of my list just so
you know being his presence but I think
it would be very exciting to try to do a
song with Elon Musk
I'll ask him well after the podcast I
was very much expose yeah so he's
probably busy yeah I could always make
as easy as possible just go to SpaceX or
Tesla where yeah